so today we return to the wilds of tick
tock to check in on their dating advice
they're apparently a bunch of
tick-tockers who have deemed themselves
worthy and qualified to dispense dating
and relationship advice to the
hapless people who use that app now i
think you already know how i feel about
this i've made it clear before i've
already specified that if you want to
give relationship advice you're not
qualified to do that unless you have to
be married at a minimum and if you're
married and you want to give marriage
advice to other married people then you
have to have a good number of years and
a few kids on your resume also but if
you aren't married at all
then you haven't beaten the dating game
yet right you haven't you haven't you
haven't completed it you haven't cracked
the code so why
would anyone listen to you it's like if
you're giving advice on how to climb a
mountain but you can barely make it up a
flight a step without getting winded or
breaking your ankle or something like
why would i go to you for advice on this
now i'm guessing that most if not all of
the advice on tick tock is from people
who do not pass this test but
we'll check it out anyway and let's
start with this
so you're talking to a new guy and he
asks you
so what is it that you look for in a guy
like what kind of qualities do you like
in a man
let me tell you why you should never
answer that question up front
first of all the only reason a guy's
gonna ask you that question is that he
can find the fastest way to get you
hooked because if he knows what you want
he's just gonna be that person even if
that's not an accurate reflection of who
he really is he's gonna put up that
front because he knows that's what you
want so rather than give him a literal
cheat sheet on how to manipulate you i'm
going to tell you how you're going to
answer that question
you're going to tell him
how about you show me who you are and
then i'll let you know if you're the
kind of guy i'm looking for that way
he'll take you seriously because he
knows you're not easily manipulated and
you're gonna save yourself a lot of time
because you're gonna know within a few
weeks whether or not that man passes
your vibe check
stay woke
okay to begin with uh she's wearing way
too much makeup i felt like i was
watching that scene was that scene in
the joker was putting the clown paint on
that i felt like i was watching that
scene only there's a lot better life
advice to be found in the joker than in
that video
notice something about this girl and the
tip she's giving she is perfectly okay
with the idea of dating a guy who will
manipulate you she just wants she wants
you to stay one step ahead of the game
and manipulate him instead so this is a
competition of people manipulating each
other it's kind of a zero-sum
competitive sort of approach to the male
female relationship
that has made it so that
people like the girl in the video
will probably be alone and unhappy
forever because that's the way they
approach male female relationships
listen if you suspect that you're with a
guy
who you can't be honest with
because he'll manipulate you with the
information you give him about yourself
then just dump him head for the hills
bye bye
that's the ultimate red flag right there
if you have to worry about being
manipulated it's the wrong person and if
you think that every guy is going to
manipulate you then you yourself are not
fit to be dating because of this this is
the way that you're going into it this
is how you see men the truth is that
plenty of men out there
would ask the question
about what you're looking for in a man
because they actually want to know and
uh because they want to know if they're
the right fit for you and they also want
to know if you're the right fit for them
it's not less honesty up front it's more
tell her
the truth get it all out on the table up
front right away you should be totally
clear
both of you
about what you're looking for what your
values are etc that's that's what you
should actually do and you can take my
advice even though i wasn't putting on
makeup as i gave it
let's continue if you want someone to
like you more there are some really
specific psychological things you can do
that can actually make a world of
difference as a relationship therapist
i've literally spent my career studying
the art of attraction and human
psychology so i know that these things
work the first thing you're going to do
is take advantage of the reciprocal
liking concept when you see them in
person you are going to act so genuinely
excited oh my god i'm so excited to see
you and catch up on all the things we
talked about last time you're probably
thinking but kimberly like shouldn't i
be playing it cool like shouldn't i be
waiting for them to come and talk to me
and the answer is absolutely
you're gonna treat them like you have a
very special connection and this is
because our brains are psychologically
primed to like people more when we know
that they like us and think we're a good
person this isn't even a flirty thing at
all this is literally that they feel
safe and seen with you and they know
that you see the absolute best in them
next thing you're gonna do in your
conversation you are gonna point out
something that is similar about both of
you oh my gosh i can't believe we both
have a sister
wow the human brain does unconsciously
choose people who we view as similar to
us next thing when people especially men
see bear skin they get aroused
i hate to admit it but the sundress
phenomenon is a real thing there is a
reason why guys like these so much your
comfort is key when it comes to dressing
in front of anybody but if you want to
play it psychologically it will not hurt
you to show a little bit of their skin
finally this is the kicker if you are
not in a relationship you're going to
make sure that you give other guys the
time of day this brings out a protective
instinct in guys and is usually the
exact moment
they decide to lock it down i mean
seriously what is with the makeup thing
i don't understand
why would you record a video while
you're putting makeup on
like it would never occur to me to whip
out my phone and take a selfie video
while i'm getting ready in the morning
and putting makeup on i've never been
brushing my teeth and said to myself you
know oh this would be great content
anyway this woman has spent her career
she spent her career
studying the art of attraction which
means that she's been studying it for
about 12 days because she looks to be
about 19 years old and she's telling us
about what she's learned in her long
career
and the super secret
psychological insights she giving us
she's giving us are as follows if i
remember them this this again she had
she would show it to school for this she
studied it she's an expert she's getting
advice she's putting her makeup on and
this is what she tells us people like it
when you show interest in them and they
like it when you have things in common
and then the big one
the big secret
nobody could have known this without
studying relationships in school first
you gotta go to college pay a hundred
thousand dollars spend four years
studying and read a bunch of books and
after that then you will know
that men
like it when women have less clothing on
no way
that's that's psychological people don't
know that so men did you know this
heterosexual men are attracted to the
female form what knockers that's a
hundred thousand dollars worth of
education that tells you that
so that that's a what'd she call it the
sundress phenomenon yeah that phenomenon
you heard about where where men like to
see women in short skirts it's true do
you think miniskirts are in good taste
on you i think they are
the rumors are all true okay
her counseling degree confirms it all
right let's uh let's watch the next one
all right
i told you guys to stop giving such a
big and you guys responded you were like
cool cool but like how do i do that this
is my best advice to you
start thinking like the man that you are
or talking to okay
when you are able to do this and you are
able to start visualizing the
relationship for what he sees it as the
game is changed and this is what i mean
when you go hook up with this man stop
thinking of it as a little
date night a little snuggle that okay he
is seeing it as a hookup so when you go
hook up you need to see it as sex and
you're out your shift is over baby
you're gone because that is what he sees
it as genuinely if you are getting your
brain on you this is why because you're
thinking of it in a perspective that
he's not with
texting him every five seconds give it a
rest play his game on him mind [ __ ] a
little bit have fun i love you
let me give some advice inspired by that
video um and i give this advice to some
men
if you meet a woman who wears so much
makeup she looks like a department store
mannequin
that's a red flag
and if she uses phrases like [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
then that's the final red flag no woman
who's like ever uttered that phrase is
marriage material it's like that's a
that's right there it's it's over shut
the door
of course though in acting and speaking
like a teenage boy she's only following
her own advice she advises women
that some men are only in it for sex and
um
i think we got but we got to go back and
check with that with the uh with the
counselor with the college degree first
to verify that i'm not sure they get
aroused but the claim here is that there
are some men who are just interested in
the sex
and that's what she says and you know
these men they don't care about you
personally and they they don't want
anything deeper out of relationships or
out of life probably and her great tip
is to adopt the same mentality so stoop
to
the lowest common denominator
give up on wanting something more
something better out of life and out of
your relationships as the man descends
into selfishness nihilism emptiness
superficiality descend with him
and then at the end
you'll both be equally alone and
miserable
success
i guess we are all prostitutes in one
sense or another